قالت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه جاباروجيا ان شخصا قتل واصيب اخر
بجروح في قصف روسيا على بلدات عده في
الاقليم وذكرت الاداره ان القوات الروسيه
تنفذت 130 هجوما طال 27 بلده في المقاطعه
خلال اليوم الماضي كما اوضحت ان 116 قذيفه
استهدفت بلدات عده منها يورو كيفكا
وقد الحق القصف دمارا في 15 او في خمسه
عشره مبنى سكنيا
كما نشرت قناه
المقربه من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقطع
فيديو قالت انه يوثق شن ضربات جويه على
مركز تحكم ومركبات اوكرانيه في مقاطعه
دونيتسك الشرقيه اوكرانيا اظهرت الصور
لحظه اقلاع الطائرات المروحيه وشنها ضربات
جويه بعد ذلك على مواقع اوكرانيه دون ذكر
مزيد من التفاصيل بشان الخسائر البشريه
والماديه التي احدثها القصف